bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction ce soir il sera
notamment question de la gronde contre
la journée banalisée du 8 octobre les
enseignants qui sont appelés à une
consultation par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale une décision prise
à la dernière minute et qui agace les
parents qui vont devoir s'organiser pour
ce mercredi qui sera donc et qui sera
donc férié en quelque sorte nous
découvrirons aussi au chili c'est une
lilloise elle habite montigny le
bretonneux elle se prépare à participer
à la nouvelle émission musicale de m6
rising star et puis invité josé et jules
cache un père et fils ils seront sur
scène à la salle jacques brel à montigny
le bretonneux pour une représentation et
ce sera pour récolter des fonds pour
aider les personnes en situation de
handicap vous le découvrirez tout à
l'heure avec chaque année dix mille
engager l'armée de terre est le
quatrième recruteur de france ce
mercredi matin les 27 nouvelles recrues
des yvelines se sont retrouvés à la
mairie de versailles pour signer leur
contrat d'engagement
les jeunes signé des contrats et d'une
année jusqu'à cinq ans même pour
certains et devant leur famille
forcément très émue moi j'étais un peu
ému surtout quand il a parlé de la
famille xterra parce que je sais que
c'est important pour moi je pense que
l'âge en âge de prendre des
responsabilités
c'est une bonne chose pour moi et je
voulais sortir du quotidien les bureaux
de même de faire une simple école de
commerce
c'est pas trop mon truc et l'armé ça me
convient on bouge je sais pas ce qu'on
va faire demain par exemple il n'y a pas
de profil type puisque de recrutons 200
bac à bac 8 5
on avait trois jeunes femmes qui se sont
engagés nous ne faisons aucune barrière
pour les femmes ou les hommes on a trois
candidats pour un poste c'est ce que
disait le collège antoine sahler on se
donne le droit de choisir et s'ils sont
là aujourd'hui pour signer leur contrat
c'est à dire qu'on fait du recrutement
de qualité sur le cirfa de versailles
chaque année aussi longs entre 150 et
200 contrats d'engagement ce qui est une
moyenne qui est maintenue maintenant
depuis trois ou quatre ans propos
recueillis par william elle le mercredi
8 octobre je vous le disais
exceptionnellement ne sera pas
travailler pour les enfants des écoles
primaires et du collège c'est une
journée de séminaire pour les
enseignants concernant la révision des
programmes dans le cadre de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires
cela n'est pas du goût de tout le monde
notamment des parents catherine sultan
il a été l'un des tout premiers à monter
au créneau bernard de bain le maire de
saint cyr l'école a écrit à
l'association des maires de france pour
protester contre cette matinée non
travaillées les écoles resteront
exceptionnellement fermée le 8 octobre
et pour le maire ump il va être
compliqué de s'organiser
alors qu'il n'a été prévenue que le 22
septembre on va demander aux
municipalités d'organiser quelque chose
un petit peu dans la précipitation alors
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens
si je prends la ville de saint cyr on a
75 classe or les seules personnes pour
lequel sur lequel nous pouvons compter
ce sont ceux qui assurent l'accueil du
matin
orne le matin ya 25 animateurs de toute
façon il nous manque 50 personnes et 50
personnes
on les trouve comment les centres de
loisirs n'ont pas la capacité
d'accueillir deux mille enfants même il
même si on n'a que un sur deux bernard
de bain pointe une autre problématique
le coût de l'organisation de cette
matinée ont travaillé et il prévient
qu'il adressera la facture au recteur de
l'académie même coup de colère du côté
de la mairie ump de plaisir dans un
communiqué de presse joséphine coleman
ce berger estime qu'une fois encore
l'état se décharge de ses
responsabilités sur les villes et les
parents on ne trouve pas normal que ce
soit aux familles et aux élèves de subir
une consultation qui doit être une
consultation interne à l'éducation
nationale donc pour nous hors temps
scolaire le souci c'est de savoir quelle
prise en charge il y aura
mercredi aura t-il sur certaines
communes ça c'est déjà organisé pour
qu'il y ait un temps de périscolaire qui
sont organisées de toute la journée
pour d'autres c'est pas le cas donc ça
va être peut-être encore un peu la
pagaille
certains parents rencontrés ce matin
qu'ils ne comprenaient pas d'ailleurs
pourquoi on rogne un jour d'école
ça me pose pas de problème mais je
trouve ça un peu ridicule de nous avoir
embêté avec ces histoires de mercredi 2
jouera sur deux semaines sur cinq jours
et de nous prendre mercredi comme ça
c'est un peu ridicule
j'ai la chance d'avoir une femme qu'il
peut la garder mercredi donc elle va
rester à la maison et elle va se reposer
parce que la reprise un peu difficile
avec ce changement de rythme en ce
mercredi n'ont travaillé pour les
enfants ne concerne pas que les écoles
maternelles et primaires mais également
les collèges le département compte 1024
écoles et 137 collège politique c'était
en mars ce dernier lors des élections
municipales alexis piette maire sortant
de voisins-le-bretonneux avait perdu la
bataille à quelques voix près contre
alexandra rosetti son ancienne première
adjointe
le maire déchu avait alors déposé un
recours est mentionné plusieurs
irrégularités
hier mardi 30 septembre s'est tenue
l'audience du rapporteur public il
rejette la requête d'alexis boulette sur
le fond là mais concède tout de même
quelques voix en moins due à des
procurations sans tampon ou encore des
signatures différentes entre les deux
tours cela n'altère toutefois pas le
résultat final des élections ni les 24
sièges qui ont été attribués à la maire
actuelle donc alexandra rosetti le
tribunal rendra une décision est
définitive dans 15 jours je vous propose
d'écouter les réactions des principaux
intéressés au micro de violaines torres
oui je suis soulagé parce que quelque
part le fait que le rapporteur public
quand même rejette cette requête sur le
fond montre qu' il n'y a pas eu de n'y a
rien eu de grave en tout cas sereine
aussi pour la suite et puis je m'en
remets à la justice de toute façon que
son travail la procédure n'est pas
terminée il faut je crois attendre la
décision de la décision du tribunal
toujours à voisins le bretonneux et il
date d'une dizaine d'années mais il
était au coeur mardi de la réunion
publique organisée en mairie c'est le
projet d'aménagement de l'éco quartier
et de la remise l'occasion pour les
habitants devenus nombreux d'en
découvrir les avancées
yolaine torres et la zone d'aménagement
concertée dont il est question ce mardi
à voisins-le-bretonneux c'est celle du
projet de l'éco quartier de la remise
un projet qui s'étend sur 10 hectares de
terrain juste derrière le centre
aquatique de montigny-le-bretonneux
son objectif principal répondre aux
besoins au logement des vies si noah et
du bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
avec la construction d'un peu moins de
500 logements
la population de voisins baisse d'année
en année les jeunes gens n'ont plus de
nom pas tellement d'endroits pour loger
parce que c'est quand même extrêmement
cher et donc il est nécessaire d'avoir
une offre de logement assez diversifiée
pour permettre ce qu'on appelle un
parcours résidentiel au jeune couple qui
voudraient démarrer dans la vie et puis
continuer à vivre sur voisin après
parmi les autres aménagements prévus le
déplacement du bicross du côté de la
piscine la réalisation de commerce ou
encore la construction d'un centre
cultuel catholique financé par le
diocèse de versailles ont dit centre
cultuel parce que c'est une église c'est
vrai mais il ya aussi un tout un projet
de la paroisse pour avoir des salles
pour des séminaires pour accueillir des
associations
voilà donc ces puces c'est plus qu'une
église c'est quand même a priori un
projet de vie le projet date d'une
dizaine d'années il ya déjà pris trois
ans de retard
alors du côté des habitants on attend
beaucoup une amélioration du quartier
avec de nouveaux commerces et puis
peut-être des des jeunes qui viennent
habiter dans le coin la municipalité
continue à travailler sur cet éco
quartier
il faudra encore attendre de nombreux
mois avant que le projet ne voie le jour
pour la première fois la police
nationale a lancé une grande opération
de prévention dans les yvelines à
destination des cyclistes et des piétons
quelques jours après plusieurs
verbalisation une vingtaine de personnes
a dû suivre un stage de sensibilisation
à la sécurité routière anthony rech
à pied ou à vélo ils ont été contrôlés
en situation d'infraction au code de la
route
au lieu de payer une amende de 135 euros
cette vingtaine de personnes pouvaient
bénéficier de cette formation à la
sécurité routière de deux heures au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
si certains campent sur leurs positions
et se trouve de bonnes excuses à leurs
infractions
d'autres ont changé leur comportement
sur la route j'ai l'impression que
respecter les règles ça permet aussi de
mon d'éviter de créer du désordre sur la
sur la route et quand les choses sont
bien ordonné il ya moins de surprises
pour les gens et d'autres moins
d'accidents avant cette réunion
j'étais un petit peu encore un peu
rebelle un peu comme tout le monde là je
serai un peu plus attention certains
vélos circulent désormais sur le
trottoir ou ne respecte pas les stops
une accumulation d'incivilité que
combattent les forces de l'ordre tour à
tour les référents de la sécurité
routière un assureur et des pompiers
tentent de faire passer leur message
le conducteur de vélo pour lui il n'ya
pas de loi ils font n'importe quoi donc
pour eux le vélo c'est traditionnel on
peut rouler on peut faire les feux
rouges
on peut tout faire venir ici et d'écouté
qui a une réglementation pour tester une
surprise dans un premier temps
l'objectif c'est de les sensibiliser
leur faire comprendre qu'ils aient un
code de la route mais c'est surtout leur
vie qui est importante moins on a de
tués et de blessés sur les routes
mieux c'est c'est le comportement c'est
le civisme enfin caen en 2014
cinq cyclistes et quatre piétons sont
décédés sur les routes chinoises culture
la nuit blanche c'est ce 4 octobre et à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cela se
déroulera notamment l encours dans le
quartier 17 mar plusieurs performances
vont être réalisés nous avons suivi tout
un parcours chorégraphique qui sera a
proposé voici les dernières répétitions
catherine mulato clair quand bien même
si vous arrivez pas tous ensemble
d'avoir ce temps vous suspendez et ici
il se touche font contrepoids là il
déambule et font des gestes qui semble
étrange c'était ce samedi dans le
quartier 17 mar l encours un travail
préparatoire à la nuit blanche qui aura
lieu le 4 octobre
pourtant tout est coordonné les ordres
viennent de leur casque on entend des
démos et en fait on doit les faire on à
les imiter mais en très grand donc on
entend balayer donc on doit balayer
sauter sauter
retourner sur la scène du prisme ils
doivent suivre des couleurs là encore
pas de place à l'improvisation
on nous explique ce qu'il faut faire les
couleurs qui font les chemins de
couleurs qui vont emprunter on a un
tempo pour marcher donc à en rythme et
en se balançant un peu et puis on n'a
pas besoin de fonds me dit de mettre
l'épaule en arrière ou de machines main
sur l'épaule du voisin la nuit blanche
va investir plusieurs lieux le prisme
ainsi que la médiathèque 17 mar le
signer cette la librairie du pavé dans
la mare et la commanderie des templiers
aux manettes deux chorégraphes dont
david rolland j'ai invité une galerie
contemporaine la galerie père tv de
nantes ainsi que julie coûtant une autre
chorégraphe
on a plusieurs types d'interventions
puisqu'il y en aura qui seront par
rapport aux oeuvres d'art plastique qui
seront montrés à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur du prisme on a aussi une
déambulation participative qui s'appelle
api manif ou là ce seront les
spectateurs qui mettront le casque et hf
que je leur donnerai et qui déambuleront
dans le quartier à la découverte des
oeuvres d'art classique et il y aura
également des interventions de
conservateurs et puis rossi dès les
commandos chorégraphique tout le long de
la nuit ces élèves danseurs amateurs ont
même imaginé leur propre duo un travail
participatif à découvrir samedi prochain
à partir de 18 heures dans le quartier
17 mar unis blanche qui lance un nouveau
rendez vous les samedis 17 mar
régulièrement le quartier va battre au
rythme des performances artistiques
le 7 octobre à 20h45 la salle jacques
brel va accueillir la représentation de
l'apprenti de daniel keene une
représentation dans le cadre de la
semaine du handicap puisque les fonds
récoltés permettront d'acheter un
fauteuil roulant pour l'association
handisport bonsoir josé cache un soin et
bienvenue élue à la culture à
montigny-le-bretonneux vous êtes surtout
le metteur en scène de l'apprenti vous
serez sur scène avec votre fils jules
qui vous a accompagné ce soir et
bienvenue également avant de parler de
cette pièce qui réunit père et fils un
mot sur l'engagement dans le cadre de la
semaine du handicap n'est pas une
première pour vous régulièrement vous
écrivez vous scénarisez ces pièces
pourquoi cet engagement déjà c'est exact
effectivement ça fait trois fois
maintenant qu'on a cet engagement là
j'ai déjà écrit deux pièces il ya deux
et trois ans nous avons également joué
dans la semaine du handicap
c'est à nouveau le cas de cette année ce
n'est pas une pièce que j'ai écrite mais
néanmoins j'aime j'aime jouer des pièces
qui sont à but caritatif
voilà l'engagement et simplement à ce
niveau là on joue pas pour faire une
recette
pour nous le très précisément on joue
véritablement pour pour aider pour aider
les personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap
cette année c'est pour l'achat d'un
fauteuil roulant
on a eu les années précédentes un
reversement de la recette qui a été fait
au niveau du ccas l'année suivante à
l'association handisport voilà tout
simplement
qu'est ce que vous aimez aussi monter
sur scène parce que vous êtes rabbin
bien évidemment vous êtes enseignant
mais vous avez aussi monter sur scène
bien évidemment oui bah on sait en tant
qu'enseignant déjà je monte un peu sur
scène et des représentations
voilà mais là c'est un petit peu
différent elle vient d'où cette passion
juste pour le théâtre je pense que
j'étais la passion elle est due à
plusieurs à plusieurs choses
déjà je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
naturel qui fait qu'on aime on aime
monter sur scène comme ça moi j'ai la
chance
dès mon plus jeune âge d'avoir pu
d'avoir pu jouer un certain nombre de
pièces de théâtre dans le cadre de ma
scolarité au collège
voilà j'ai épousé une femme dont le père
était également metteur en scène donc
j'ai eu aussi l'occasion de jouer à ses
côtés et puis voilà de fil en aiguille
j'ai toujours j'ai toujours aimé ce
contact direct avec le public
je me suis mis à l'écriture également et
puis cette fois-ci ben c'est pas une
question d'écriture c'est surtout une
question de pouvoir jouer avec mon
physique le mans c'est dans les gènes
voilà je l'avais envie de jouer avec
vous c'est ce qu'on m'a dit valeur et
c'est vrai ouais je sais déjà plusieurs
fois que je suis demandé si je pouvais
jouer avec lui il disait que j'étais que
j'étais beaucoup trop jeune ou après des
jeunes présentent bientôt quatorze 14
morts qui peuvent maintenant je sais que
cet apport adresse web il ya il ya un an
de ça à peu près je crois imai mais il
m'a proposé un sujet et puis j'étais
assez attiré par part ça donc j'ai dit
j'ai dit d'accord et puis et puis depuis
on s'est lancé dans le projet et puis ça
me plaît beaucoup ont parlé de ce sujet
justement tout d'abord il ya aucun
regret de monter sur scène
non il peut saluer subir la direction
artistique père sur the way mais ça va
comme on s'entend super bien parce que
parce que c'est mon père donc et puis on
s'éclate dans la pétition donc c'est
super c'est devenu un loisir père-fils
aussi simple qu'un sérieux la pièce
c'est l'apprenti de daniel keene
l'histoire la rencontre d'un homme et
d'un jeune garçon à la recherche d'un
père idéal on regarde un extrait de
l'une des dernières répétitions qui on
revient juste apprend plateau cinq
minutes me trouve et je suis sûr que non
alors pourquoi il dit julien qu'est ce
que tu peux être m je suis sûr c'est
pour plaisant alors on prédit une
plaisante valent bien une personne plus
bête que je peux l'être
il était peut-être en colère contre toi
à quantitatif mais je vais jamais en
relais les trials toujours oui c'est
possible ma mère aussi
voire à vie mais on a la même direct
alors qu'elle a indiqué à l'express va
te laisser finir ce que j'essaie de dire
sur ali excusé
père et fille sur scène le 7 octobre à
montigny le bretonneux jouer ce genre de
pièce justement avec un fils qui se
cherche un autre père un meilleur père
ça vous a fait sourire sur scène par
contre c'est par lui que j'ai trouvé ça
génial parce que c'est vraiment un rôle
de composition finalement de jouer deux
personnages que rendra de psychanalyse
dans le sur scène il ya un côté un peu
psy qu'analytique quand même un du fait
qu' on soit père et fils dans la vie et
que dans le texte même il ya un certain
nombre de propos qui sont tenus et ses
terrains et qui prête à faire sourire
malgré tout parce que les gens qui
viendront savent pertinemment qu'on est
père et fils dans la vie donc je trouve
que le mariage des deux fonctionne à
merveille
en fait vous n'avez pas une envie ou
d'un risque aussi peut-être de sur jouer
justement certaines certaines scènes en
se disant comme on est père et fils on
peut peut-être insister là-dessus bas
principalement pour moi parce que moi et
déjà j'ai moins d'expérience que mon
père ça va il m'a bien briefé je trouve
donc satisfait la prestation du fils sur
scène écoutez moi j'ai je suis très fier
je suis très fier de jouer avec mon fils
mais je suis surtout très fier que ce
soit mon fils je peux pas vous dire
mieux
merci millions ce qui se passe sur le
passé c'est l'amour de l'amour paternel
voilà non non non je pense que
voilà on va passer un très bon moment
sur scène tous les deux on joue de
certaines situations bien évidemment il
ya certains propos notamment quand quand
je lui pose la question de savoir si
s'il est un bon fils voilà quand ils me
demandent si pourquoi je me suis pas
occupé de mon père et que je lui réponds
est-ce que tu t'occupes rates ton père
quand il sera vieux voilà donc tout ça
voilà ça fait l'amalgamé un petit peu de
deux situations différentes et je pense
que ça fera sourire tout naturellement
cette pièce vous n'avez pas écrite cesse
d'utiliser tout à l'heure alors que
d'habitude vous êtes plutôt friand de
l'exercice mais c'est vous aviez du mal
à écrire une pièce pour vous deux en
fait ben c'est pas que j'avais eue c'est
que je n'y suis pas arrivé du tout c'est
à dire que à partir du moment où il
m'avait fait cette demande d'écrire une
pièce qui puisse nous nous concerner
tous les deux mois j'étais parti sur le
principe effectivement de mettre une
pièce qui relaterait une relation père
fils etc
on est je suis assez rapidement tomber
dans une relation conflictuelle qui
finalement est un sujet qui est assez
souvent véhiculés bon à l'arrivée
y'avait pas il n'y avait pas de choses
très très original dans tout ça donc
j'ai vite abandonné l'idée je me suis
mis à la recherche d'une pièce qui nous
conviendrait rapidement vous avez fait
la recherche de cette pièce l'apprenti
c'est tout de suite et est convaincu bah
non pas tout de suite j'ai quand même
j'ai quand même lui livre avant avant
que sar confirmé et puis non non le
sujet m'a bien plu ça me fait rire donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas se lancer là
dedans donc aujourd'hui tout est prêt
encore des répétitions presse presque
presse presque qu est ce qui est arrivé
non des petits ajustements techniques
voilà on a essayé on a essayé de mettre
en forme vraiment une
une mise en scène contemporaine sobre
jolie esthétique enfin tout ce qu'on
veut et bien évidemment sa demande
encore quelques réglages techniques mais
sur le fond on est plus que prêt oui
c'est à ses premiers exercices sur scène
pour toi le 7 octobre on le rappelle si
vous souhaitez bien évidemment y
assister et en plus c'est pour la bonne
cause ça donne d'autres envie de
continuer à jouer puisque c'est toi qui
la demandaient déjà de pouvoir monter
sur scène bah ouais ouais moi j'aimerais
bien refaire une pièce avec lui pourquoi
pas ensuite j'ai eu quelques idées mais
allez découvrir que la décevrai pas
encore parlé à donc voila mais ouais ça
me ferait plaisir de continuer à faire
ça parce que parce que depuis depuis que
je suis petit enfin il fait des pièces
de théâtre du coup ça m'a donné envie
vraiment
de faire ça si tu avais suivi des cours
de théâtre déjà ou par non non non non
c'est le tout début peut-être le début
d'une carrière alors juste une précision
si vous le permettez pour terminer en
fait la pièce affiche complet là vous
déjà prises non alors vous savez que ça
affiche complet ont fait une entrée au
chapeau
donc il ya plus de billets à disposition
mais on sait pertinemment que bien
souvent lorsqu'on a des représentations
comme ça on a un taux d'absentéisme qui
avoisine les 5 voire 10 % donc c'est
pour ça que si toutefois certaines
personnes sont intéressées pour y
assister
elles sont cordialement invités sachant
que elles pourront à terme rentrer dans
la salle jacques brel parce que je pense
que certaines personnes oublieront très
probablement devenir puisque l'entrée
vous l'avait dit et au chapeau chacun
donc voilà ce qu'il veut donc on réserve
sa place mais effectivement quelques
fois du coup on oublie de venir dans ces
cas là merci à tous les deux les six
spectacles 7 octobre à 20h45 salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux
culture toujours mais dans un autre
style rising star le nouveau show
musical interactif de m6 jeudi soir
c'est une habitante de
montigny-le-bretonneux qui va essayer de
faire se lever le mur des votes des
téléspectateurs rencontre avec o'shea
c'est son nom aurélia de bissy
ve
minable tu étais formida j'étais pas
une fois mon étape
je suis ici j'ai 18 ans et j'habite à
montigny-le-bretonneux jetez pas vos
gains promis juré
j'ai envie de participer à rising star
car c'est une nouvelle expérience c'est
un nouveau projet c'est nouveau et c'est
le public qui vote et je trouve ça
important parce que c'est les gens après
qui nous écouteront et pas forcément
toute la production du ca qui m'appelait
froid
je pense que c'est une étape importante
de passer par ma part un télé crochet
car aujourd'hui se faire connaître sans
passer à la télé dès le départ c'est
assez difficile même si elle est réseaux
sociaux qui joue beaucoup je pense que
c'est un bon moyen se faire connaître et
d'être apprécié aux jambes at il argué
comme elle consacre j'ai commencé la
musique à l'âge de 6 ans par le piano je
faisais juste des courants conservatoire
très peu en fait parce que le seul fesm
a pas beaucoup plus ensuite j'ai
commencé la guitare il ya trois ans et
c'est là que j'ai commencé à composer en
fait avec le fc malines tine et
justement j'ai fait plusieurs scènes
avec avec mon ancien groupe et
bah c'est important pour moi la musique
parce que c'est vrai qu'à l'âge de 6 ans
m'a découvert d'importants problèmes
d'oreille et du coup pour moi c'est
vraiment une revanche de pouvoir vivre
de ma passion ma rigueur pour l'instant
et la peur dit mamie si papa trompe
maman c'est parce que maman veillée
tient pas pourquoi tu sais tout rouge à
vos biens gamin mais qu'est-ce que vous
avez tous à me regarder comme un singe
lui ah oui vous êtes simple banque de
macaq donnez moi un bébé sans gilet sera
formidable
cet effort dit que c'était faux mais la
date à chelsea physique or je me suis
fait tatouer deux semaines maintenant et
pour moi c'est ça veut tout dire
faut du travail bien sûr mais il croire
ses principales
les médias s'étaient pas non
merci de nous avoir suivi le journal
revient jeudi même heure il sera bien
sûr question de l'élection à la
présidence du sénat de l'illinois gérard
larcher l'élection est en cours si vous
ne suivez en direct aux alentours de
18h30 un second tour va se dérouler dans
quelques instants à la présentation
demain catherine gélato je vous
retrouverai vendredi pour une édition
spéciale du journal depuis le mondial de
l'automobile à paris excellente soirée
bien sûr sur l'antenne de télé fils